Okay, it is May 19,
2022 and it's week three of the textbook
group first cohort. We're in week three
discussing appendix A and B and
there are some notes in the sections of
the book. In the chapters. There are
also some ideas and questions that
people have raised. So we'll go
to the questions and then start with the
most upvoted. So feel free to add more
upvotes if you want to
discuss it, like even in this
discussion. And then hopefully
if people are available to take notes in
this section, that will help add their
thoughts in and also capture what the
speakers are saying. And then we'll look
at the question and then try to
come to different answers and just add
more information that people can add
more structure to later.
Okay, the first question says appendix A
is described as the mathematical
background. So maybe question
one for the authors or for you. What is
the process of determining what is
figuring ground for the formalisms of
active?
What other math concepts and formalisms
are important for learning and applying
active inference? And then three, what
are some resources and approaches for
learning math that help us learn what is
useful for active inference?
Anyone can raise their hand or we can
just start to add some annotations here,
like what should be included in the
primary regime of attention with a
reading of a book, either linearly,
like some books are, or in a maybe
moving around the sections. So what
should be in the chapters? What should
be in the appendix? What is not in the
appendix?
What did people expect would be in the
chapter in the appendix? Not covered.
Yeah, Jessica and then anyone else?
Yeah, I was wondering about the
multiplication of the matrices that we
covered yesterday. Which equations
have the multiplication of the matrices?
A couple of examples just so I can play
around with them.
In the actual active inference
equations.
Does anyone know? One,
this is referencing the way that the
appendix A is starting with linear
algebra and then introducing this
operation of multiplying two matrices.
Or to get a product if someone can
find like an equation that we already
seen or some other equation while I'm
typing up that question, that would be
helpful.
Could anyone just describe what they
thought the intention was of starting
with linear algebra and using 8.1 as the
first equation of the appendix? Or we'll
return to just the more general
questions.
Yeah, I mean, learning our algebra is
kind of the most discreet.
I don't. Want to say fundamental, but
like practical and comprehensive way of
kind of working with a large space of
data, I guess, together and
computing on it. So it's kind of the
basis for the discrete parts
and maybe easier than the nondiscrete
parts. Good reason it started.
I guess if the question was where
is linear algebra used in the active
inference math?
When you go to appendix b.
Then you've got the equations of active
inference and these are all expressed in
terms of large vector spaces of
variables, so probability of
distributions. And so for example, on
page 245, you've got this dot notation
which is the expectation of a value.
So that goes directly back to
that first section of appendix A is what
does that mean in terms of how do you
take an expectation of a large vector of
things? How do you express that
compactly?
Thanks. Could you unpack we looked at
the dot notation a little bit yesterday
and they were mentioning how
well, I think it was actually one of the
questions too. Let's just see if someone
asks this, okay?
They say the dot operator in a
three, the dot operator
is equivalent to standard matrix
multiplication where the first matrix
has been transposed. So what is the
relationship with expectation?
How does expectation for anyone, how
does expectation relate to linear
algebra?
Yeah, expectation is the probability of
a value, the average probability of some
value. So you're going to take all the
possible values and you're going to
multiply them by the probability of that
value and then divide by the sum of the
probability of normal is to one. So that
will be the expectation. So if you have
a whole array or a vector in your
distribution, you can express that all
in compact notation by saying with this
simple way of saying we're going to take
every one of these terms and we're going
to multiply it by the probability of
that term and the probability is
some to one. So then that will be your
average overall.
Awesome, thanks for that answer.
Okay, thanks for that awesome answer.
Does anyone have any other thoughts on
just this first question and then we'll
continue. So what is
figuring ground? We're learning active
inference in the chapters. That's why
the chapters are there. The appendix is
there to somehow lightly supplement
that. Like they describe it as an
introduction or a refresher to the basic
mathematical techniques. And linear
algebra is the first section, a two
that is discussing a lot of important
things like derivatives and
Probabilities taylor series variational
calculus and Stochastic dynamics are
going to come in in the coming chapters,
but the linear algebra is important for
the upcoming chapters.
Okay, so this question asked in
a three.
They say the dot operator is equivalent
to standard matrix multiplication where
the first matrix has been transposed,
which is flipped like it's the operation
in Google Sheets or Excel right click
paste transpose. They say that in the
case of column matrices, this is
equivalent to the dot product. So the
dot operator here is like a
generalization of the vector dot
operator, the sum of the products of the
corresponding entries of the two
sequences of numbers. So the questions
here were what is interpretation,
implication or use of a dot product of
vectors? And then what is an
interpretation, implication or use of a
more generalized dot product. And there
looks like there's an awesome answer.
What would be a situation where if
anyone can think of one, like the Dot
product would be applied.
We're trying to do this in this
situation. This is the operation that we
needed. We wanted to compute matrix A on
something of something. We used
B dot C.
Continue eric's description from
the probability like you have
expectation probability and you wanted
to kind of see the error or whatever
the difference, I guess between
observation and the expectation,
then a Dot product would give you that
answer or it's
a probability density of it.
What are some ways to compute
differences? Like if
there are scalars you can subtract like
five minus three or something, then it
was mentioned of cosine similarity.
Does anyone think of or imagine another
way that you could compute the
difference between two different kinds
of features of
different dimensions.
Like another example is divergence
because that's like measuring the
differences between these two
distributions and there's different
divergences. The KL is one of them.
What other things are in this space that
might be just tractable possible
distance measures?
Well, these are the same dimensionality
in all these cases. But another very
popular one is the sum squared
difference, sum squared error.
And then you can have absolute different
value difference. So these are called
different norms.
I think that's the right word. Yes.
There's also the Ginny index, the Jacard
index, euclidean distances
like sample to sample distances.
So could anyone talk
about L zero, l one and L two, et cetera
norms? While I'm adding some links.
If I have the right numbers here l two
norm would be the square root of the sum
of squares. L one norm would be the
average of the absolute absolute value
differences and L zero. I don't know
what that is. I don't think it's a
difference, is it? It's like a presence
absence. Okay.
That kind of encoding is used in a lot
of different algorithms and
then the L two norm is the sum of
squares. So the L two norm is what is
used like in at least squares
regression, classical statistics,
ttest inova that's a
lot driven by the L two norm.
And all of that is like in the
genre of what the A three notation is
describing.
But depending on what the B and the C
are and what the A is, et cetera,
there's just the dimensions of
everything and other operations that are
happening before or after it.
Later on they mentioned the quadratic,
which is the L two norm. So that's where
you have the same term as multiplied by
itself. Or if you have cross terms,
then you get the covariance.
And that's going to be used later with
the LaPlace approximation and other
approximation techniques.
Any other comments on a three or dot
product? Or just like this kind of
linear algebra topic?
Linear algebra the basics,
the trace and the determinant, which are
probably less important than the dot
product but still come into play,
the derivatives, how things change with
respect to each other, possibly time,
possibly some other surface,
and then probabilities.
So does anyone have any other comments
or thoughts on that whole section? Like
anything that they read or like had
uncertainty around up to equation A 22?
Great. That no one has uncertainty
around any of the equations up to A 22?
Yeah, obviously there is a
lot to learn and to understand and we're
not going to.
It's just I don't know people who want
to think about that. Like, what are we
learning in Appendix A? Why is appendix
A there?
Hopefully we can start to understand
some of this in Math Learning Group.
The people who want to be really engaged
with the math questioning and process
and also connecting it to computer
science into the applications has been
happening and then hopefully everyone
can benefit from this, like finding the
resources and stuff. Because the
relationships between the terms,
relationships amongst the terms are
driven by formalisms.
Like the way that preferences and
expectations are framed in active
inference is related to equations,
not only a conceptual linkage.
Maybe here we can just write Math
Learning Group and copy this to the
resources.
Okay, so what kinds
of examples do you think would be useful
for learning the equations and concepts
in Appendix A? If the equations felt too
general and not applying to anything in
particular, what example or scenario
or would have made sense or you felt
would have made that clearer?
Like, we're running a business and first
this person wants to do this and then
this person wants to do that? Or what
example or what would somebody have
expected to have found or wanted to have
found that would have made it clear?
Examples or other exercises or
a format? This is kind of like a math
lecture. It's kind of directional versus
like, what other things could happen
where you would feel like you were
understanding and learning this and
engaging with it. Yes. Thanks, Brock. I
was kind of reminded of a video that
Karl A presentation where
he in real time demonstrates
and helps you work
through a pattern of red. Like it's like
three dots sort of that are moving
around red, green and pattern. And so
understanding just a simple visual
example of how active inference
would work that
doesn't require
the formalism to just
surface level kind of pattern
recognized, that would be like ideal
maybe of then bringing in the math for
this part and that part and some
scaffolding. But yeah,
I'm not sure the appendix, I'm not sure
it was meant to be bred in. I'm not sure
there's a great way to read one order or
another there because you kind of need
it, but you kind of it's
a lot too, right? Yeah,
great point. And the organizing
team for the textbook group which was
open to everybody who wanted to join the
and the comms weekly meetings. So for
future cohorts, people could totally be
involved with planning it,
communicating it, doing anything for
future cohorts as a co organizer or
other role. But we talked a lot about
the reading order. Would it make sense
to read them in without
appendix or putting the appendix last or
somewhere else? One was
short and hopefully the one week of
regime of attention on appendix A and B
is like we're just skimming it in a
week. We're not getting a
PhD in math, we're not generating these
equations on a blank piece of paper.
We're just like seeing the forms that
will be used and then some of the key
areas in the order that the authors
thought that those background topics
were important. So like for appendix A,
linear algebra, which is what we talked
the most about, because it's going to
come into play most quickly,
especially with these notions of
expectation and differences which is
going to come into play with everything
that's going to happen. Taylor series
variational calculus and Stochastic
dynamics we talked less about.
They happened in a later order within
the appendix, but hopefully there will
still be many questions on them because
they're probably also areas with a lot
to learn and to clarify. And also
appendix A is like not the final
resource of it diffusing into us. Like
something that was really important that
came up in the math learning group. Is
there's not like a glossary of variables
or table of variables so that's
something we can work on with notation
is connecting the variables to natural
language ontology terms and then also
things like this what do we even look up
or a symbol or what does it mean when
there's a double arrow? There's a lot of
things that like a lot of dots that
could be connected if people ask them
and then we can probably get a response
like what was the double arrow in a
three? Does it mean anything that
they're offset? Or what are the parts of
this shape that are mattering for the
background of learning? Active
inference, anyone can ask like any
question. If it's coming to mind as an
uncertainty, then writing it down just
anywhere is really helpful. Because then
on the first pass through learning or a
primary branch of learning, we can just
go, okay, here's what a one shows,
and then have that in a way that reduces
uncertainty more rapidly than how any of
us would just give an ad hoc
explanation.
Moritz wrote one thing that I
always find useful in thinking about
matrix, linear algebra matrices is to
write out pictures of the matrices in
their dimensions because often the
notation, you've got these I's and J's
and K's and stuff going around, but you
don't know how that maps out into the
actual elements of the matrix. So those
illustrations are always helpful that
could be added into this book. They're
in a few places, but not that much.
There you go. Things like that.
Yeah. And also connecting the
programming experience that people might
have even in no code tools like Excel
Google Sheet, you have rows and columns,
ones have numbers and ones have letters,
but they can be other things. And then
anyone who's used something like Python
or R or even just doing some statistical
calculations, like if you put two lists
of numbers into the t test, that would
be vector versus vector something, and
then you would address the fifth element
of the list. And then if it was in
Excel, you would need to address two
numbers to say where you were in the
matrix. And then the tensor is just any
number of more than three dimensions,
which is sometimes like it's like, oh,
but how spatially are we going to see
it? But then we're familiar with working
with spreadsheets and data sets that are
larger than two by two or larger than
two dimensions,
and that will come into play a lot.
And the numbers can be representing
probabilities or be used for
probabilities. I also
Daniel in the chat shared a link to a
Python notebook that is a link, and it
shows kind of the operations on
matrices. And you can see both the
mathematical yeah, there you go. So you
can see the actual matrix and you can
actually run code too, there. So that
particular awesome. So I pasted the
link in here and then we can
fill out the rest of the row.
But then someone
could be looking for a guide on matrix
or programming and matrix or something
before this state. So then each person,
if they find it and add it here, will
have a lot to share and learn.
Okay, does anybody want to like, if they
were the one who asked it this question,
I i think it's probably referring to
long equations that that probably none
of us are ready to give answers to at
this point. Unless somebody wants
to contextualize this question.
I'm hoping a read of chapter four will
elucidate when the time comes. Just
exploring the formal foundations here.
Okay.
Does anyone have a favorite or
recommended textbook that it contains
the KL divergence and Dearsley
distribution in the index.
This is for the math learning group.
Okay. Maybe we could tag some questions
too, and so then we can know which ones
they can look at. Wikipedia is good.
The Kale divergence is approachable.
The deerish lay is tougher. The links
take you to definitions that enable you
to put the pieces together.
Okay, any comments
on KL and Dear schley from
someone who is familiar? Otherwise it
sounds very technical and we don't need
to go into it right now.
What is up with dividing by sigma in a
31?
Also detail, but we'll
just see if there's any questions that
are not going to be specific details
because math is very hard to understand
sometimes on the fly and there's
definitely a space for the interactive
discussions around math that are
unrecorded which are important.
However, this is a little bit of a
different format, which is how I'm
hopefully interpreting people's activity
rather than their disengagements because
they are here and hopefully have at
least scanned these chapters.
Anyone can raise their hand at any time
or add questions or upload things.
Mean field mode,
equation nine, equation 16 probability
resource,
statistical question,
appendix B just to see if there was any.
Also seem like all details. So we
have 23 minutes. What does anybody want
to ask now?
Or is there some question here
like the most upvoted one or some other
one that's far less challenging that
they would like to address for the next
20 minutes?
Did anyone read Appendix A or B
visually?
Did you just ask if anyone read it?
Yes. What would anyone like to share
about reading it?
I totally read it with a highlighter and
made several notes in the margin in my
physical book. It was challenging. A lot
of the notation I feel like is
crazy,
even just independence b was it the very
first thing? Are they using O for
observations or are they using O for
outcomes? I was totally unclear on that.
Completely. So like state inference,
Markov decision processes like the
states that influence outcomes O,
right? Literally. That's what it says on
the top of page 244. So it says that the
variable O is an outcome. Is an outcome
and observation. Are those the same
thing? Are they interchangeable? I've
always thought O was observations. I put
that question in there in the past.
It's already there and
then the question right before it. This
is a really tricky section. Right? So
the two questions that are in Appendix B
that are together, it says the
likelihood of observations given a
policy is not straightforward to
compute. This is because POMDP problem
is structured so that policies pi
influence trajectories indicated by
tilde of states S that influence
outcomes o without a direct influence of
policies on outcomes. The problem then
involves the sum over trajectories of
states to marginalize these out and find
a marginal likelihood of observations
given policies. Like what does that
these even refer to? If you look in the
questions in Appendix B, they're there
in the questions already listed.
I felt like it was very obscure and not
super clear. And also the notation gets
crazy and I'm really a stickler for
defining every single variable and
symbol in an equation to understand the
math so that I can actually read it in
English. So I was a little bit lost.
Totally agree. Thanks for sharing it,
Eric. Just with respect to that
particular question, I think that
these refers to the trajectories of
states and you can see that because the
sum is over the tilde s. So the tilde s
is the trajectories of states.
So you sum over all the trajectories of
states to try to figure out, well, what
are we going to get if we apply a given
policy? That's my intuition about that.
And I suspect also that observations are
outcomes. They're sensory outcomes.
They're the outcome of a generative
model or a generative process, but
they're the outcome that is observed.
How many dots we need to actually unpack
and connect for unsighted grammatically
vague sentences. Right. So thank you.
My uncertainty has been reduced
substantially just by figuring that out.
But I felt like that the whole time I
was reading the appendix, I was like,
what is even going on here?
Yeah.
Sir, the way I view it is like
exercising. You're not going to run a
marathon the first time you set out,
but the more you
stretch and warm up and I think that's
how I kind of view this. Going through
the appendix is kind of refreshing on
what you used to know about math, at
least for me. And so that's like
stretching and doing a little bit of
exercise last week. And then every time
you go through it, every time you see
the notation, you've slept on it some
more, it becomes more and more familiar.
And so you can start to put together
bigger, bigger chunks. Some vaguely you
can map to the notation and the math.
Other ones it's still going to be
dangling, but that's okay because
there's fewer dangling things that
you're groping with at any given moment.
So I think it's great to go through
these dependencies and see it all
through one pass and all right, so I
didn't run a marathon, but that's okay.
I ran 2 miles. That's pretty good for
first start. Thanks,
Eric. Another metaphor is just like,
oh, yes, please. Jakub.
Yeah, I was just going to comment
on what Blue said with
some confusion about the notation
because I asked the question about the
marginalizing of state. But then I was
also confused about the O notation
because in equation B
one, it seems that it's a trajectory
over outcomes. But then there's also an
O without a tilde on it. So does that
mean that it's an outcome at a
particular point in time? But then
there's also a bold o,
which implies that it's kind of a
vector. But if it's a trajectory of
outcomes, that also seems to be a
vector. Like a trajectory for me implies
some kind of vector form because it's a
sequence of outcomes given a policy.
But then what does that bold O
mean if not trajectories over outcomes?
So just to kind of add
to the confusion, I guess.
Thanks, Jacob. I'm glad we're groking
we're on the same page, you and I for
sure.
It would be awesome for description or
any notes. What is the reading or a
reading in language?
The this of this conditioned on that is
this over that of these two things.
The first thing is this. The second one
is that an example of that is in this
situation, here's the script, here's the
graphical abstract, here's the paper,
here's the person you could ask, which
one of these do you think is going to be
interesting?
Okay, so Mike asked, and I'll copy this
in for those who have read the entire
book. Did you find the appendices useful
as you went along through the chapters?
Ali.
Yeah. I also think that if the materials
in these two appendices were to be
integrated in the linear
narrative of the whole book, it would be
much more useful than separating out as
separate appendices. Because.
As we see, that's my own experience.
Well, reading the chapters independently
and in isolation of the narrative
doesn't give me a sense of their
concrete applications and I don't know
how to use them and how to use all
of these equations, and everything
becomes much more fuzzy.
I hope this is not controversial. That
linear reading of the appendix as
something that you look through is
extremely confusing or extremely
imprecise because there's many symbols
introduced that might have been
introduced earlier, like O is probably
discussed earlier, but then it's
briefly just sort of mentioned. And then
there's a lot of symbology that's not
mentioned. What it is. So it's hard to
read the appendix without prior
knowledge. Yet, ostensibly, Appendix A
is the introduction refresher.
So is this the introduction offering?
They hope so. They expect and prefer
perhaps the appendix to go some way
towards remedying it being
the maths required to understand this
not complicated basis.
The multidisciplinary basis means it is
often difficult to find resources that
bring together the necessary
prerequisites they're going some
way. So this is like one kind of plank
out there from their point of view,
from the chapters. This is stuff. Ali I
also kind of agree on what ordering
these are really interesting questions.
So then what is the next connector
that picks up here with this artifact?
Because someone mentioned how Moritz
mentioned you could basically do a whole
course on deep learning to apply most of
the matrix operations and whole courses
on the math of them so they can't go
into all this detail. They can't spend 1
hour or like multiple coda pages on
just what this means. So there
has to be some kind of compromise, but
then there's not going to be one
specific perfect compromise,
especially with like, length and
audience considered.
I undertook a very detailed linear
reading of the book because that's just
kind of how I am, of the appendixes at
least. But I think for many people that
I've been there before, where you're
staring at math equations like this is
gibberish. Just to read the text and
to read it and go through it, it's
helpful to know that it's there. So if
nothing else, at least you can be
reading the book and then be like, oh,
I remember kind of reading about Taylor
series expansion in the appendix. And so
then you can just go back and just
having access to it or the refresh
recall access, even though it is
confusing. I agree to try to a linear
read of the appendix.
I think skimming over it or deeply
reading it and then being able to refer
back to it is useful. Thanks, Blue.
So in next week,
we're going next two weeks. So the pace
of one section per week might be like
whatever it was for you, however much
time you put in, et cetera. The coming
chapters are going to be very different
because one didn't have any formalisms
or figures really, just the kind of
overview figures. But we're going to
have two weeks for two. So no need to
rush it. Read a couple of pages and then
just go back to the beginning and just
restart the same pages. That's like the
multiple coats of paint in a mural.
Like the low road to active inference.
That's where they're going to pick up in
that high road, low road dialectic
that we talked about last time. Let's
just see what figures, what equations
might happen. Okay. Lot of terms that
hopefully are in the ontology already.
Like you can use the at symbol hopefully
to call most of them, but if something's
not there, we can add it to supplemental
or entailed. Okay, so what figures
and figures and equations will we might
see? Here's a box 2.1
about probability.
Here's an equation that's the
Bayesian kernel and
it's going to be talking about this
example of a frog and an apple and
jumping or not jumping. And that example
is going to play a current role. But
then some likelihoods are shown in a
specific example of like frogs and
jumping or not and apples.
There's a work through example of exact
Bayesian inference.
Here's a table on statistical
distributions.
It would be really interesting, like to
hear what support and surprise mean and
what are these district? Are these all
the distributions? Are there other ones?
Or like why these ones? Or why are they
useful? Where have they been used? What
does it even mean?
Here's where the KL divergence is
introduced and then some more analysis
from a surprise perspective. Bayesian
surprise with the KL divergence.
There's the box on expectations, which
is also what we talked about a little
bit today. And that was really
interesting to connect it to the
matrices.
A figure of the generative process
and the generative model is the caption
a figure both perception and action
minimize discrepancy between model and
world free
energy.
Variational free energy as an upper
bound on negative log evidence the
figure but with equations in it. Very
common format figure
complementary roles of perception and
action in the minimization of
variational free energy. Big act,
imp theme and like something kind of a
common fristinism like perception and.
Action, being in the same game or being
in the same service of the same
objective function.
Planning but no specific
equations but probably citations.
Just introducing expected free energy,
which Yaakob and others can probably
go into a lot more detail on.
Expected free energy about a future
where the outcomes haven't happened.
Expected free energy figure with
equations, the end of the low road.
Introducing the two key terms
variational free energy, expected free
energy summary
does anybody, like, want to, like, add
or what was something cool or whether
they read it already or not?
What does anyone Ali? Yes, please.
Well, I've noticed the dispersion of
some sidebar boxes like box 2.1 or
in this chapter.
I don't know the distinction between the
purpose of these boxes and I mean,
what's the function of these boxes as
compared to what we see in the
appendices? Because presumably these
boxes cover the concepts that could be
skipped over if one is familiar with
these mathematical concepts. So do you
have any idea about the reason behind
this decision? I mean,
covering some basic concepts, basic
mathematical concepts in these sidebar
boxes and some others in the appendices?
That's a great question. A box could
reflect like, okay, expectations.
Got it. Or like, okay, some product
rule. All right. But it's kind of like
you might want to read that. Or is this
introductory highlighting it? This is
the 101 on probability.
Or is it saying this is a total
skippable unit? If you want to learn
about how the lizard does it, here's
where you look. It can sometimes mean
both. And the format of the book is also
relatively austere, though in
a concise tone.
It's in black and white, which
especially in some later sections make
some visualizations where it's like it's
hard to understand what curves are doing
what it's a black and white image, so
what is there to see with the color?
But it also might predispose
towards more simple or visually
accessible material.
So what is going to be accessible and
the order. So those are all really
important questions. So we can just take
notes on it in the weeks that we're
going to continue to do this because we
only have limited live time. How about
in the last like 3 minutes? What does
anybody think about the opening
quotations or specifically this
quotation? My thinking
is first and last and always for the
sake of my doing. William James.
I thought the guy was a philosopher, so
I guess you just abused me of that one.
I.
Yeah,
these would be really nice areas to look
into for people who like the history
part. Blue and I and
others are working on some different
kinds of ways to reference papers and
just up cool paper. Sensation
perception. We have those terms. We
could just link the paper somewhere. So
if anyone's like, interested in that
kind of architectures or that
kind of philosophy question the
literature right now. Is small enough to
know what has and hasn't been done in a
lot of areas that are philosophical and
applied and technical.
But just from, like, the first
principles, what does this seem to mean.
That shared that other group that
we're kind of both a part of Daniel
Liminal dow thing. That's not really a
dow. I don't know what it is, but
there's this debate for some reason
that's going on there about different
ways of knowing and being and
doing and a bunch of stuff that
is kind of a mix
of philosophy and linguistic fallacies.
But if
thinking is actually a physical process,
which I think anyone here is going
to argue against, then it is something
necessarily that is being done.
However, I guess, small, you want to
draw that Markov blanket. And then
however large, whether that's your
physical body actions or some extended
thinking, it's literally what
you're doing.
It's not just for the sake of your
actions, but they are your actions.
They're just another set of your
actions. All right. I'll offer a
different take on it. Yeah. Awesome.
William James was a great visionary,
and he foresaw Mark's Mark Zuckerberg's
metaverse 120
years ago or whatever, and he said, no,
I don't want to live just inside my
mind, inside the metaverse. I want to be
out in the world, interact with real
people and real things. So he was a meta
or Facebook skeptic way before his time.
Okay. Thank you, Ali.
Yeah. As Brock mentioned, I think it
relates to an epistemological
distinction between propositional
knowledge and how to knowledge. And I
think this statement by this statement
here tries to blur this distinction,
blurs the line between propositional
knowledge and know how knowledge.
Because especially in analytical school
of philosophy, there's always been
a very, let's say
not a heated debate, but there's a
long standing debate about
the distinction between these two kinds
of knowledge and whether in fact they
can be distinguished from each other or
not. Thank you.
Could you just unpack what are the two
kinds of knowledge again, and what are
just they referring to?
Sure. Well, about propositional
knowledge well, an example of
propositional knowledge is to know the
exact mechanisms of walking.
I mean, which muscles contract and which
I mean, in what angles.
The whole thing about the biomechanics
of walking, the whole knowledge about
the biomechanics of knowledge can
constitute this kind of propositional
knowledge. And it's totally different
from knowing how to walk. I mean,
a three or four year old year old child
has a know how knowledge of walking,
but not necessarily where
he or she doesn't know anything about
the biomechanics of walking. So the
biomechanics of walking is the
propositional knowledge. Actually,
knowing how to walk constitutes the know
how of walking.
So when people say things like active
inference is integrating perception,
cognition, and action, maybe it is
rethinking some of these long held
mental frameworks for distinguishing or
operating differently on action and
perception. Like, one fascinating
recent example from me and working with
Eric was in the area of ant
pheromone modeling. Without going into
too many details, people often modeled
preference as a function of the absolute
amount of pheromone on trails because
that's what the exponential, like,
decay is on. That's what can be
manipulated rather than the perceived
intensity, which might have a different
scaling relationship. So it's like a dim
room, you can detect a small change.
Bright room, you can't detect a small
change. So that kind of psychophysics of
perception gets ignored implicitly
because of calls for measurability,
because the cognitive can't be measured
directly. Even if you potentially had an
electrical measurement or something like
that happening,
then these are awesome questions. Can
you think without acting or is thinking
in action?
This active paper, which was
on a live stream, so we can provide the
link to it.
Models like perception and action in the
sort of like kernel level, just the
autonomous sensing sentient bot level.
And then attention and metacognition are
both related as actions to
the lower level, which is like why the
paper is relating computational
phenomenology with mental action.
Again, just to have a look at the kinds
of models that can happen.
And then now does making any model,
fitting any data well enough and saying,
well, we modeled it as action. So is
thinking in action? Will that model that
says, yeah, it's consistent with that,
will that ever constitute positive
evidence for saying thinking is action?
Or why even say that?
Or what does it mean to say it?
And then here's a funny meme.
Here's the generative model and the
generative the partially observable
Markov decision process. Here's Karl,
Friston,
Jessica and then anyone else.
Yes. I guess it's like a beginning
understanding of this. I tend to think
that there's like a bias towards action
in active inference. I think the first
chapter is saying even if you want to
sense or perceive, you have to do some
kind of action in order to gain the
information. And this
quote is basically saying like, okay,
even though the whole field is trying to
understand cognition,
what we decide to do and the thinking
that we go through in order to determine
our policy is to determine our actions.
And then it sort of feed into the
thinking itself. So maybe that's why
there's like the bias to action because
our actions is what it's going to be
allowing the thinking. But when
we update our models or trying to come
up with the policies that we're going to
be doing, like, we have to be processing
things. So the thinking is in
as a service to action.
That's sort of like what I was thinking.
I don't know, it's a little bit like the
chicken and the egg, but I
kind of tend to think of it. It's like,
yes, we have to act in order to
understand, but the understanding
which will be coming from the thinking
is what determines our next action.
Yeah, that's kind of what I was
thinking.
Matthew. Thanks, Jessica.
Yeah, it kind of seems to me like we're
stuck in a little bit of a linguistic
Godellian loop of some sort because
thinking is essentially a verb and
verbs tend to imply, in a linguistic
emergent term, actions. And so we
have to then pop outside of that and try
to consider with our internal mental
processes how to disentangle these
concepts. But I see no reason to think,
ironically, that internal mental states
aren't also conscious parameterizations
of processes in the brain and our
ability to grasp control of that to some
extent. And so it seems very strange to
me to try to separate those
linguistically from our current vantage
point, even though I understand why,
historically, working only with
language, it might have made sense. So
those kind of quotes like James strike
me as somewhat antiquated
or just operating on dichotomies that
don't seem to make sense given that
we've unpacked these processes to the
degree we have.
Thank you, Matthew. Very deep points.
Like you mentioned, thinking as a verb
implies action. And then just to kind of
complete that thought is like the word
for the noun form of this one. So then
what does that imply?
And then also, like Jessica mentioned,
to. Some extent that we can only express
processes through their discretization
via symbols. Right. The idea
that there's this process, there's a
flow, there's something that can't
necessarily be separated,
obviously, from the rest of the flows
around it. But to reference it, to point
to it, to describe it, communicate it to
another agent, we have to nounize it
kind of like which is the opposite of
verbalizing, so to speak.
Wow. Thank you, Matthew.
Again. These are yes. Eric.
Sorry, I didn't have anything. I didn't
have the hand was yeah. So Karl
Friston had an influential 2019
paper. Long paper.
The free energy principle for a
particular physics. That was in 2019.
So it's been several years since then.
And like, particular allegedly
accidentally or intentionally is a pun.
So it can mean specific, like a physics
for the specific systems that we're
modeling. Or it could be specific, like
this is a specific approach. Another
interpretation is like it's for
particulate entities when we
define thing and the partition, which is
going to coinstantiate, like the
generative model and the generative
process and then the Markov blanket or
the interface that's separating them,
that is separating the figure from
ground. It's separating, like, the
entity from the niche. It's separating
what from what? What can it represent?
The separation of something from all
possible separations, some separations.
And then, Matthew, you mentioned, like
yeah, verbalizing speech, but it feels
like we're speaking nouns sometimes.
Yet verbalization is a process,
especially dialogue. Yes. Matthew.
Could I ask a question that brings in a
little bit of content from the other
chapters of the book is that yeah,
sure. I'm just kind of curious because
when you're talking about those, you're
talking about the Markov blankets and
integrating it into this idea of how we
draw boundaries. I'm kind of curious.
Is it fair to say that to the extent
we've drawn our boundaries and do see a
reduction of free energy in this system,
it reinforces the idea that there's
something to that boundary structure
as an entity in the world, that there's
a reality to that? Is that a fair
interpretation?
I think many people would have a lot to
say and add. This touches on the
question of reification of scientific
models and the
ability for identified statistical model
to be like transcending itself and used
in a realist way, like ontologically
real about true joints of the world.
And I'm going to go to live stream
table and find several of those
who explained their research on this
topic. But even short of trying to claim
it's real, does that ability like once
we've drawn a boundary using these
Markov blankets and we do see that
it seems to be, let's say, using
information to self evidence,
do we? Think that that's I mean, it
seems. Like. This paradigm
of thought is predicated on the idea
that to the extent that that occurs and
reduces free energy, it should attract,
or further attract attention, at the
very least, for examination or
investigation.
Yes. So, great questions, Jacob. Do you
have something to add on that or is it a
slightly different area? I guess it's
kind of related to the Markov blanket
discussion.
This may be completely wrong, but it
seems to me like with that,
this kind of discretization of the
Markov blankets forces us to a specific
kind of discrete thinking. But I feel
like that just this model of a
Markov blanket. I think of it as a kind
of classical model, but I presume that
the reality is more something like a
schrodinger Markov blanket where we
can't really draw boundaries between
thinking and observing a generative
process. In the same way that we can
think of, say, electrons as balls
bouncing off each other, but we can
think of them as classical particles and
that will help us to an extent,
but then we can also observe the
process of thinking. So thinking is also
kind of entangled with the generative
process. So even though
the Markov blanket is a useful
formalism, I think that there
are definitely certain scenarios that in
which it's more like a probabilistic.
Well, it's already probabilistic, but in
the sense that the entity that's
performing inference also in
its own inference loop
performs inference on itself and
therefore thinking is at the same time
an action, but at the same time it's
part of the generative process.
Another angle on this thanks Jacob,
is what Dean T often talks about with
active inference as a framework or a
filter. These are just sort of like
different distinctions that might be
transiently useful in some axis, like
fitting something to a framework. It's
kind of the procrusty's bed. Stretch it
out so that this perception and then
active as a filter, was reminding me of
what Matthew was saying, like going out
and discovering divergences from
expectation of there not being metabolic
activity on a planet. And then there is
some statistical deviation.
And so, like, in the classical
statistical framework, that might be
like it's a one sigma difference in the
Bayesian framework, well, there's a base
factor of two. And here for this
evidence, and there's other ways to talk
about detection of novel entities that
might be part of, like, a reification
process of the extended cognition
of the modelers.
Then, like, one philosophical angle on
that. And then also anyone who wants
to read, then Ali is this book by Helen
Longineau which talks about
methodological pluralism and about how
there can be, like, disciplinary rigor
and the ways in which often unstated,
like social priors can be
the substance of what becomes understood
to be science as, like, a complex
phenomena. Ali and then Brock.
Adding to what Yakov said, I think
the concept of Markov blanket emanates
from the Plutonian way of
thinking, specifically hylomorphism
school of thought as
opposed to hylozoism. The distinction
between hylomorphism and hylozoism is
that, well, in hylomorphism,
everything is disconnected. Every
concept is disconnected and with
every other concept. And so there's a
discontinuity, metaphysical
discontinuity between the concepts.
But in hylozoism,
the philosophers advocating this
school of thought, well, they claim that
hylomorphism fails at answering
the question of what it is adequately,
and they even rephrase the question.
And they claim that the right question
to ask is not what it is,
it's what it can do. So that's basically
the distinction between hylomorphism and
hylozoism. But I think the mark
of blanket is a way of formalizing
this hylomorphic way of
thinking. At least that's my opinion.
Thanks a lot for that, Ollie. Eric?
Sorry, I'm not hearing Eric. Can others
hear Eric?
Maybe I need to reload. Can you
hear me? Okay, I'm going to reload.
Can you hear me? Yeah, I can hear blue.
Okay. You're still not hearing Eric,
though? No, sorry. Yeah, I just did,
like, a small disrupt.
Okay, wait, eric, try again.
Okay. How about now? Yeah, now I can see
you in here again. Okay. How about
everyone else who's the audience?
Okay. Wow. Disrupt on the high low
field. It's happened before.
I just throw in my two cent about my
interpretation of a markup blanket.
It's about trying to perform
simplifications that make computation
tractable. If you have everything
interacting with everything else, then
we can't do computing on that. So we
apply compartmentalization and
build objects and interfaces for how the
objects interact with one another,
and those become tractable.
That's what a
Bay's net does, is it says what are
independent and what are dependent
variables on each other. And that works
well when those abstractions,
the objects and relations, nouns and
verbs are a good fit to how the world
actually operates. So that is a driver
for learning or building representations
that will use these Markov blankets and
put the compartments where they actually
are faithful to the compartmentalization
that we can abstract over the way the
world parts in the world operate. So
things that are distant, that separate,
that interact only weekly, we try to
maybe factor those out, pretend they
don't interact at all, or use some other
intermediate variables to represent the
interaction in order to simplify things
so we can do computation. So that's how
I think Marco blankets and we'll see if
the math tells us that later on when we
get to it. Awesome. Brock ethanoli.
Okay. I'm like not hearing Brock,
unfortunately. Do you? Yes, we all
hear Brock. Brock is reloading, I think
now. Again. Okay. Yeah. Gather does this
sometimes, but I don't
know if it's because we have 15 people.
Yeah, but like Matthew said, I don't
hear him. It's just like there's
different drop offs.
I can hear you, but I still think Daniel
can't hear you. Daniel, you can't wait.
Now you're back. Go for it. Okay,
continue. Interesting. Can you hear me?
Yeah. Oh, okay.
Yeah. This is just this ongoing thing
that I don't know, we just keeps coming
up about. Yeah, well, okay, maybe they
exist, maybe they don't. Markov
blankets, really? But how would they
form in any how
would they form an evolving collapse?
Presumably there is some point
in that process, this evolution part
where the Markov blanket is
extremely poorly defined relative
to the system and that's basically
these sort of underexplored areas. It
was also in relation to Matthew's
question also about the free energy
minimization thing where there's systems
like non equilibrium systems
basically, where still something
interesting worthy of study is
happening, but perhaps is not
free energy minimizing in
that state. Thanks for
sharing it. Just a few thoughts.
Let's just say some sort of meso scale
or global as that's called, but that
doesn't mean about the whole world, but
some sort of global free energy
minimization in the joint model is
achieved like in a conversation that
isn't the same thing as the local
disconnected free energy minimization.
Otherwise fitting high parameter models
optimally would be simply reducing to
fitting single dimensional models alone.
If we could just do the linear
optimization on the standalone
variables, then why would we ever need
the larger dimensional methods? And then
think of this textbook maybe with
where things could be in the coming
years. The Markov
membrane is like the linear algebra.
And then Jacob mentioned that this is
classical model. It is kind of classical
in a sense, in the timeless classic
sense. So the one layer Markov
blanket when thinking about the rise and
fall of civilization is not the
end all that's. Like I think maybe
analogous to a linear regression y
equals MX plus B and then you have all
these hundred years of development on
the linear regression model and all
these techniques and applications and
pipelines. So the Markov blanket
one layer potentially over interpreting
it as already presenting with strengths
or weaknesses in certain situations when
not being just like empirically
demonstrated. In the general case,
we'll see what could be said and when.
Matthew.
Yeah, along those lines, I was kind of
curious. I've seen that there's been a
decent amount of work on the sort of
hierarchical or fractal composition of
these models. I'm curious if that
implies that there's a fractality to the
boundary by default or if there needs
there any specific work on sort of
hierarchical composition of the
boundaries of that so called membrane.
As you said.
With better annotation, we could have
better answers because there's many
papers that we've discussed in a guest
stream or a paper and there's also like
many other papers obviously, that we
don't have that kind of annotations of
because it's quite common to see nested
models in the context of nesting
of cognitive processes. Like in that San
Fed Smith paper, which was I think,
number 25. That was about cognition as
mental action. So that was nested and
the nesting was interpreted as cognitive
actions and counterfactuals, basically.
And then sometimes nesting is used to
refer to actual, like, well, the state
is inside of the country and then the
region is inside of the state. It's
implied that the map is mapping onto the
territory, maybe even spatially, the
cell is inside of the tissue. And that's
like answering Schrodinger's question.
Everything happening with the planetary
scale analyses, cellular level.
And then this is hopefully what is
spoken to with the composability of
active inference. And sometimes that's
framed in terms of the lateral
composability of you could have three
ants interacting or 300 ants and
then the nested composability,
you could have the fifth and the 7th and
all those layers with computational
trade offs, maybe with no extra
information to be gleaned. And then
learning the structure of the generative
model or just the structure of the
partition more broadly and like what the
variables are and everything that's the
structure. Learning challenge and
cognition as structured learning.
Hashtag synergetics geometry of thought
is what Friston has and others have
raised as like a total open area because
there's the parameter fine tuning once
you have the Bayes graph. So then
you're now inside of the ability to
reify or not that model. You're just
doing parameter optimization. We used
two factors in this linear regression
and then we optimized it with the L two
norm. Two is the best number of factors,
but it couldn't be set at that scale.
You could say in a two parameter model,
this is the best parameters with this
norm, but then you couldn't pull back
another level. And so that's like meta
scientific and metabasian analyses,
which they're going to talk about later.
Okay, I guess I'm also kind of wondering
if there are any examples that come to
mind of something like a system that is
structured. Such as the clearest or
simplest example that comes to mind is
like, let's say that you have a nation
and a state within that nation and there
is a port and there is an overlap of
sort of that port interface to an
outside structure that is shared by both
the national and overlapping national
and state interests and decision
processes. And so I'm kind of curious if
there are examples of demonstrating that
kind of composability of generative
models or if that's something that's
still just new and open.
Those are awesome questions. If people
know any some areas to investigate,
like in the phenomena that you're
overlapping interests informally, there
would be like shared regimes of
attention. There's the question of
synchrony and that doesn't mean like
synchronization identically but
generalized synchrony.
Then there's like coordination of
affordances. We're not going
to do this because of that. So that's
like in an area that Yaako
and others have been working on is just
describing that situation as an
affordance on an affordance or like E
sub E. It's not in the textbook. But if
people are staying this long then this
is just kind of some ways that some
people are thinking about it. And these
are the areas where people can also do
research and learning with us. But
affordances on affordances,
the safety could be on or off. So then
there's like an affordance that modifies
another affordance and could those have
compositionality just like some of these
other generalization
affordances for generalization
basically, what are those? And then
isn't it like discovering what those
are?
Just I think it's
kind of also related to that question of
this formation evolution, collapse of
markup blankets is when does the
observation and actions of one system
map to the
preferences of another and vice versa?
How does that come into being
existence? How does that start to happen
and how does it unhappy? I don't know.
Awesome question. Thank you. And another
angle on that, let me just check and
then Ali is like this is a graph that
we're going to look at a ton and we will
interpret what all of it means. What is
the OASB, pi, g,
et cetera. But this
is a basing graph like Eric mentioned.
And the edges are like dependencies,
not causal influences in the world, but
apparent potentially or different
interpretations. Is this the only
skeleton? No, this is
the Y equals MX plus b of skeletons.
And there's the linear regression in the
first equation in the textbook of the
stats textbook. And then there's all
these accessory tests. Then there's like
creation and destruction as applied.
Maybe there can just be a loop that's
not active inference, just checking
every day if something's within an
arbitrary threshold. So there could be
some liminal or gray area like
an interface. I think steven Solette
mentioned it as like a nail bed or
something, like an interface between
more particulate and then less
particulate, more field versus the
particle. Ali.
Well, as a little side note,
there's a popular science book coming
out, I think in June, namely The Romance
of Reality by Bobby Azerian, which
touches on the
emergence of Markup blankets, the
dynamics of emergence of Markup
blankets. And it attacks
it from many different angles,
evolutionary angle, I mean, from a
cosmic, even perspective. And it
even goes as far
as well, considering the
whole cosmos, the whole universe, as,
let's say, a kind of Metamark
of blanket, so to speak. And well,
I think that could be an
interesting thought put forward
by Bob Yadarian in this book. All right.
Thanks, Daniel.
Thanks. In fact, he gave part one of
what was intended and may still be like
a multiple part discussion,
but this was him giving that
presentation. So we
were in contact is definitely an
interesting view. And it's going to take
all kinds of research and education and
communication. Jessica.
Yes. I guess first,
join the lab. Some of the ideas
that helped me a little bit to start
even conceptualizing this,
in addition to the filter that you
mentioned before, Daniel, and how it
could be more like porous or more hard
and allow things in and out, but it was
also about it could
be like just grouping of relationships
and interactions. So, like, the closer
like a relationship, like different
things are, maybe that's more like on
biological systems, I don't know if
they're closely related or they have
more interactions, even though they
might be different, but grouping it in
those sense and maybe that relates to
what Eric said from the calculational
part. But that was sort of like some of
the things where I started connecting
Marco blankets to.
Okay, if items
or different objects and things like
they're closely related, you can start
putting a blanket around and
maybe go through with the idea of
wrapping things from some of
the definitions. But, yeah, those are
kind of like the kind of visual ideas
that started helping me a little bit
and I still don't understand properly,
but those are the things I was like,
okay, so relationships, filters,
kind of like connecting interactions
between things.
Awesome. Thanks a lot for that. Like
interacting entities. So you could
have the edges representing some
interaction, like when people are
fitting a linear model. Interacting
variables. So there's this whole
discussion topic of whether the
interactions are like the two ants
bumping into each other, whatever that
means in the, quote, real world. And
then there's like the statistical
interaction. So then defining
certain variables in statistical models.
So leaving that debate behind us and
just talking about the statistical
models that we have, Bayesian graphs,
some variables have edges between them
that could be either designed to be
there or not. Or you could do some sort
of like thresholding. Approach and
explore that your thresholding parameter
was acceptable. But the more of a loose
interaction you allow, the more
challenge there is to fit that
statistical model. And you may not have
enough data to fit like the ten variable
by ten variable with all the interaction
terms which is like why when doing
linear modeling in a health population
example they would like do model
selection on what their statistical
power is with that data set to resolve
certain kinds of effects and
correlations and non sphericities. And
that is addressed a lot in the SPM
textbook and Kristen's earlier pre
active work. But then you mentioned how
to be engaged with that process of the
wrapping or the seeing the clusters and
then knowing where is there going to be
maybe generative models arising that are
consisting of other generative models or
other generative processes? And then
some things interact more with others
statistically in a model as by design or
just as an outcome of whatever.
So there's sparse connectivity amongst
the variables. They're not like all by
all connected. And then that sparse
connectivity simplifies a lot of things
that's also related to like a Lasso
regression and also to the below l two
norms and then a sparse model can be
factorized. And that is what allows for
the variational Bayesian inference,
which is like doing Bayesian model
fitting on a factorized because it's
sparsely connected graph and
so a lot of these discussions are quite
downstream of a lot of the philosophy of
map and territory. But it's still a
super important conversation. However,
within the model inference, with a model
inference using a model, a lot of these
questions are very technical and
downstream of importance qualitative
things that are also important to keep
in mind but of a
different type,
jessica or anyone else.
Yeah. Wow, very interesting.
Here's one other question I guess we can
discuss. Like as the as it currently
stands, there's a 1 hour meeting and
then at the end of the hour, the very
next hour begins the Tools regular
organizational unit meeting.
It is the people who are here now but
hopefully others would be listening to
it if they're not able to make this
time. But what will help
people with the synchronous and
Asynchronous make the most of the next
few months? Do people appreciate having
a longer discussion for this?
Do people think that the main versus the
math group? Is there another subgroup,
like a philosophy discussion, that
people want to kind of really do this?
Because we're experimenting with
open endedness on our first cohort and
in these early phases of the book and
people can probably imagine various of
the things we want to balance, like
respecting everyone's time and different
backgrounds, respecting their
preferences for how much they want to
learn about different topics. Being
realistic about how much asynchronous
and synchronous, direct and peripheral
time makes sense. But also being
realistic like there isn't a two minute
video for a process. So how
do people think about that, those who
have stayed this far?
Mike and then anyone else?
Can you hear me? Yes. Okay.
Yeah. I think that as noted earlier in
the discussion, there are just so many
themes that run through this that there
are opportunities to pull on any of a
number of threads in the course of
discussion. And so today's discussion
was interesting and I stayed for this
part of the discussion simply
because of the interesting threads that
were being pulled. Certainly a contrast
with the first part of the discussion
around math and I think a lot of
uncertainty amongst the attendees about
how to engage with the mathematical
aspects. Maybe to try and put
a point on it, from my
perspective, learning about what
is active inference and how can active
inference be applied in real world
situations is a motivator for me
participating. Obviously there
are also sort of philosophical and maybe
more scientific discussions that can
take place.
Any meeting could touch on any of those
aspects as well as some of the
asynchronous interaction could pick
those up as well.
Thanks a lot. Okay. Anyone can
raise their hand here's just a few other
options. Like if somebody here's
something that's interesting to them,
we can in the discord make a channel
that is relate or people can participate
in the regular channels just like
questions that's going to potentially be
seen and interacted with by people more
broadly. Like what if we posted
questions that we're having we're in the
cohort one of the text and we had this
question do you know that's one option?
Another, and this is like to Mike's
expression that applied active inference
is a motivator epistemic and pragmatic
value, expected epistemic value. We
expect to learn a lot by like staying in
these sometimes challenging
or oblique or whatever discussions. But
then there's also expected pragmatic
value with applying active inference,
learning and applying active inference.
So then maybe that is a group
we can partition, like an applied
active inference group. So then we can
be clear about what the focal artifact
is because also we want to not
all groups at all times will be able to
have nor is it useful to have open ended
discussions of any discursion length.
So like knowing how far and in what ways
and how many minutes of people's linear
time. Ali yes,
the meetings, just one note
on the organizational unit meetings.
The organization units in the active lab
like comms and tools for education,
communication and tools are like
directory 1 hour lab
meetings or group meetings because we're
not doing the education work necessarily
in that 1 hour. But some groups
sometimes it's possible to do some
stuff, but it's like increasingly moving
towards sharing updates from people who
want to commit in Asynchronous work or
smaller groups that want to commit to
doing something like that. So then
educational related projects, that's
their opportunity to ask for help,
share updates and so on.
But earlier on there was more topical
material, but then through
particularization and operations and
other approaches, it becomes more like
Pragmatic and less discovery and less
mixed media role specification, all
these processes. So people sticking
around is sort of the and being engaged
and like seeing an affordance and then
just making that contribution, wanting
to be a facilitator for a certain
project or wanting to contribute
actively or just even connect with
another participant. You can email
them if they've provided their
information, just some
random things. But we want to have
the applied angle, the philosophical
loop and how to even partition that
discussion. Like we couldn't just
overgo every math, every philosophy,
every applied question and have the
judge and the jury and all this
apparatus.
So how can we scaffold that conversation
around applied active inference for the
people who are like super excited and
motivated? Mike?
Yeah. I just want to add there's an
interesting duality related to what you
just said in that we can't go into fine
detail in all of the content and at
the same time, I've found this group to
be remarkable at unpacking things and
sort of really getting into what do we
mean when we say that? Types of
discussions and what does this term mean
not taking things for granted as going
through the text. There's a balance
to be struck in taking that approach of
asking what do we mean when we're
talking about this and putting nouns on
things and relating it to language and
not going too far over into getting into
fine detail about things.
Thank you, Lyle. And then I'll leave
with your question. Yeah, this firstly
great session, really great
conversation, I really enjoy it. Most of
this is new material for me and so I'm
really enjoying the breadth of the
conversation and I'm cognizant of this
aspect you're digging into is how much
do we sort of separate out the pieces
and go deep dive in different places
versus more of touching on multiple
threads and their interactions? For me,
while I understand there is a balance to
be struck there, I'm really enjoying the
challenge of relating as an example,
the math to the philosophy, to all these
different threads together because they
are linked. Right. I do
understand that some
of those areas need a separate group
that you can drill down into for me
personally. And so this may be not the
same as other people in the group. I'm
really enjoying understanding the
connections, the philosophy, how these
different thought process came to be
through history and get that depth of
understanding. Thank you,
Lyle. And for those who want to listen
or view, these live streams have many,
many themes. So check if there's papers
that you're interested in here. The live
streams is about papers, so there's 46
papers. Guest streams are not driven by
a paper. Sometimes the person is sharing
a paper. But these are like
presentations, hearing from different
perspectives. And if anybody wants to
help organize these, that's what we do
in comms. If they want to facilitate and
participate in these discussions, if
they want to contact authors, recommend
papers, these are all distributed tasks
that are leverage points for people who
care to just do a ton of amazing things.
Like if somebody's interested to connect
it to a given community and make an
artifact or a live stream co organize
that, we can catalyze it at the lab
scale for individuals who know about the
affordance but then want to take that
affordance to just have really
leveraged impacts in the active
ecosystem. So, ali's question and then
jessica sorry.
I don't have any questions you asked.
About the timetable for the meetings,
like what specific times are they
occurring at?
Sure. Yeah. Okay. They are on Mondays at
13 and 23 UTC.
There's two meetings to reflect, like
education being the primary mission of
ActInf lab, and then that spreads them
out by time zones. But if somebody
really wants to contribute to an area,
the organizational unit meeting is not
the rate limiting step. Anyone who has
attention to contribute will be able to
find a regime of attention that is
connected to a task that's meaningful.
The rate limiting step is not people's
availability for a 1 hour meeting.
It's however much time people want to
contribute. Whatever practices and
things will find something that works
for people who want to be engaged. So
don't take these meeting times as being
like when we're doing it, when we're
deciding. Even anybody who wants
to can email or contact just the lab
email address and be started on figuring
that out.
Jessica.
Yes. This was related to the question
about applied projects.
I was thinking that maybe one thing that
we could do is on the project ideas
to have a table where people can
briefly share what they want to do or
just say, okay, I'm interested in
machine learning and apply active
inference and maybe this specific topic.
Who will be interested in discussing
this or exploring what to do and then
adding the names of the people who will
be interested in that. So the person who
started the project, then they can
start maybe contacting those people and
see what time they can meet and start
creating their own subgroups. So maybe
that's something that we could do to
facilitate that in a simple way.
So just start saying, this is what I
would like to do. Apply active inference
while also studying the course. And we
like to connect with people here who
might share the same interest and see
what kind of feedback that person can
get. Thanks.
And just connecting and building
trust and having like a buddy system or
small groups or just people who are on
the relatively long path to apply
active inference on teams.
We don't have the speed dating hot swap
activation protocol but
connecting with people. And then however
it's authentic in that relationship.
Seeing what you're interested in in
three months will be in a pretty
different situation, but we still won't
have even gone through the second half
of the book on the application of
the textbook. So there's a lot of
time for us to develop ideas
and to connect with each other.
So thanks for sharing that a lot.
Jessica and I tagged you so that we can
create a table with the right way or do
it however is the right way because it
helps enable connections for people who
want to connect around applying.
And also it helps us remember these are
the specific reference points in the
text that are like
our attractor regime of attention for
this textbook group. Like the textbook
group isn't all of active flap. If
people want to apply active inference,
it doesn't have to be from the ground
up, but it totally could be. But there's
many ways to apply that are just in
different codas that people can get
involved in immediately.
So if somebody feels
like doing things,
I hope they feel like they have the
agency to do that.
Okay, any final thoughts on this
interesting semi
pattern breaking? And also
yes, one final thought for me is we
would have had tools organizational unit
meeting at this time, which is why near
the end I asked if you want to do
different scheduling because in
general it's probably not good practice
or ways of working to go overtime to
respect everyone's time and all of these
types of things. But also in the future
we're in gather so people who want to
keep discussing the textbook could go
there into a different room. People who
want to do Tools can go into another
place. So we need to figure out
how to do that through the
people who want to be there, like these
people and the feedback that everybody
has in the ways they want to co create
it. Tim and then anyone else who has
like last thoughts? Hey. Yeah, I was
just going to say this is generally way
more interesting than the Tools meeting
generally is.
Cross pollination shows great potential
already, I would say. Yeah, sounds good.
I just wanted to add to that
conversation, though, about someone even
mentioned Plato, Socrates and all that
and that whole sort of recursive
involution of that
raification thing you were talking about
and sort of the thought processes maybe
being almost like a recapitulation of
the structure learning and the
Kreptasian factor graphs and all that
kind of thing you were talking about
there. Plato had like a concept of
knowledge which he referred to as
recollection and this idea way,
way back where all learning and
knowledge is actually an act of
recollecting what we already know. And I
just wanted to point out there's kind of
maybe just more of. An interesting.
Illusion or connection, I guess between
those two where there seems like what's
old is new again. Or what have you
covered? Thanks,
Tim. Anyone else
who hasn't spoken or who would like to
add anything?